we felt like our family was totally
violated by the Sheriff's Department and
we felt ultimately betrayed by the
school district if the teachers start
siccing undercover operators on to their
students that trust is gone and so is
the school it's not the drugs that are
harmful anymore it's the war on drugs
that's so harmful
Temecula is a city in Riverside County
California with a population of about a
hundred thousand people it's
consistently ranked in the top 5 safest
cities in the US according to Business
Insider Doug and Catherine Snodgrass had
no worries about raising their four
children in the area particularly their
teenage son who's an autistic high
school student he also has been
diagnosed with bipolar disorder
Tourette's syndrome
several anxiety disorders and every day
is a challenge for him but he's a
beautiful boy their son's list of
disabilities have many in the community
wondering why he was targeted last
December in an undercover drug operation
their son who wish to remain unnamed
began attending a new high school in the
Temecula Valley Unified School District
last fall at the start of his senior
year he rarely made friends so his
parents were thrilled when he told them
that he had made a new friend on his
first day of school he told me that he
met a new friend in art class and I was
completely amazed by that it seemed like
they were having these great
conversations back and forth or what
seemed typical for a teenager because
there was such a furious amount of
texting going on but those texts weren't
just friendly teenage banter instead
their son's new friend was pressuring
him to buy marijuana and this new friend
wasn't just a teenager he was an
undercover cop who went by the name of
Daniel Briggs he said that he was having
a lot of trouble with his family and he
was under a lot of stress and he needed
something to make him feel better and he
just couldn't cope so our son said you
know I was worried about the guy Daniel
gave him $20 and our son said he would
find a way to get him some pot it took
the snodgrass his son three weeks to buy
half a joint of pot off a homeless man
this process was repeated a second time
when Daniel asked a third time their son
refused after that Daniel stopped
communicating with him altogether which
our son seems pretty broken up about and
he was back to back to zero friends so
he was alone again
and it really hurt him a few weeks later
armed policeman walked into his
classroom and arrested him in front of
his peers his parents were not notified
of the arrest at the time he was taken
to a juvenile facility for 48 hours 22
students were arrested in the drugs
most of them were special needs students
causing police tactics to come into
question our current policy for dealing
with this stuff is is a complete failure
we need to rethink our policy all we're
doing is using the hammer and we're
creating new nails like these children
here Stephen downing spent 20 years on
the force with the Los Angeles Police
Department located two counties
northwest of Riverside the LAPD
pioneered drug busts in high schools in
1974 the Los Angeles School District
General Council launched a review into
the undercover program in 2004 the
review found no evidence that the
program reduced the amount of drugs on
school grounds however there was
evidence of an increase in arrests of
special education students the LAPD
disbanded the program in 2005 after the
review concluded that had failed to
catch serious drug offenders in this
case there was no crime until the kid
had been talked into going out on the
street and finding something and he did
it to keep his friendship for somebody
that's a sting that's a nasty degrading
sting a Department of Justice report
likewise concluded that sting operations
in general do nothing to solve long-term
crime and that they may prevent the use
of other more effective problem-solving
techniques it can be economically
difficult for police units to disband
undercover operations in high schools
despite questionable results every
arrest they make it goes on the quota
wheel it's another notch in the quota
wheel it helps them get federal grants
it helps them get equipment it helps
them get SWAT teams built up it helps
them participate in in task force's that
pays overtime it helps them get assets
sharing that brings millions of dollars
into their departments that are
basically a police led slush funds and
so there are too many incentives in the
drug war for them to say anything other
than gee we made a big bust at the
so-and-so high school and we arrested 23
kids for dealing dope big bad dope
dealers one in two hundred youths were
arrested on drug related charges in 2010
according to the Department of
justice policy experts say that those
who get caught up in the legal system as
a juvenile are less likely to become
upstanding citizens later in life I know
kids get into trouble and with drugs and
those kids that most times successfully
escape that trouble they escape it
without the benefit of the criminal
justice system or their school they
escape it by concerned parents seeking
out the best solutions the snodgrass a--
stuck their case to court and their son
was found not guilty in exchange for 20
hours of community service he eventually
returned to school and March through a
court order the Temecula Valley Unified
School District is still fighting to
expel him due to their zero-tolerance
policy when it comes to drugs
the snodgrass have sued the school
district for unspecified damages they
claim the school officials should have
protected their son instead of working
with the police to manipulate him the
sting operation caused their son severe
anxiety and emotional distress he just
totally lost trust in in everybody and
barricaded himself in his room he didn't
want to go anywhere he didn't want to
see anybody
his anxiety went through the roof and at
this point he's being treated for
post-traumatic stress disorder we don't
ever want to see another child or family
have to go through what our son went
through
and it's really barbaric to have these
type of operations where they bring in
the cops to act like kids to ultimately
get kids who aren't drug dealers but
they teach them to go find drugs and
have them bring them onto campus so that
they can get a sell or make an arrest
and how does that get rid of the real
drug dealers it doesn't it basically
this experience taught our son how to
sell drugs and that's not why we sent
him to school
[Music]
you
[Music]